[Applause]
i know thank you i uh
please you'll make me cry thank you very
much i i know i know
please i know you're happy
because you know what it's fall
we finally hit fall the leaves back east
are turning orange here they're always
orange
yes it's fall so if you're fleeing a
wildfire this weekend please take a
sweater
but i i mean i'm trying to get myself in
a good mood the country's in such bad
shape i mean first of all what's going
on at the border there's pictures of the
haitian immigrants who went to south
america now trying to get in over our
border and you know these poor people
they say they're their country haiti was
being run by a cruel heavy-handed
government
so texas seemed like a good fit
you know the everyone's up in arms as
they should be but these photos of u.s
border patrol agents on horseback
you know whipping out what looks like
whipping certainly attempted whipping at
least of these migrants and both sides
have a take on the democrats are
demanding that the horsemen be
identified and fired and the republicans
are asking the horse
that's any leftover ivor mechden
almost got it out
speaking of that subject michael flynn
remember him he was the uh national
security guy under trump for about a
week and uh
full-on q anon this guy he is he's now
says he is worried that there are
reports of the medical establishment
trying to sneak sneak
the vaccine
into salad dressing
and not making this part up
really you think if you were trying to
get trump people
to eat something you'd put it in salad
i don't
uh
oh they're
the
crazy never stops the results from the
audit
of the election
which was almost a year ago
are in from arizona whoops they found
actually biden got more votes
really
and this was done by a company with no
auditing experience called cyber ninjas
who will now go back to their old job
playing dungeons and dragons in their
mom's basement
so
oh it's rough
so a fake company hired to do a partisan
recount
couldn't produce a [ __ ] result
and this has really shaken up maggie
nation i mean the my pillow guy today
was saying boy i picked the wrong week
to stop smoking crack
[Applause]
you